joining us the environment secretary
george eustis hi good morning see you as
always thanks for joining us on the
program start with cost of living should
last time you were on you were talking
about people buying value brands from
supermarkets in order to try to
make ends meet a little bit easier
this morning hearing from the bank for
international settlements saying that
we're on the tipping point of falling
into a period of runaway inflation
what else can people at home do
well look we've got inflationary
pressures right around the world you
know in the united states the european
union of course here in the uk as well
so the truth is that a lot of prices are
covered by the gas price and so when gas
prices spike we get a big increase in
fertilizer costs fuel costs and that
goes right through people's household
bills so there's a limit to what we can
do until the gas price comes down but we
have announced
a very very big package of support now
37 billion pounds
giving 650 pounds extra to the poorest
households in this country and an extra
300 pounds a year to pensioners as well
to give them a boost to their incomes
we've increased the national living wage
so we've done a lot of measures to try
to help mitigate the impact of this but
there's no doubt that when you get a
surge in oil and gas prices it is going
to put pressure on household budgets pm
suggested moving away from green fuels
that's uh that's a way forward he is
suggesting to tackle the cost of living
crisis um repurposing land currently
used for crop-based biofuels to grow
more food is that something that you
support yes it is something that we are
arguing for at the g7 this week and
that's because if you reduce the amount
of particularly maize and wheat that is
going into biofuels which is used as
part of the blends in petrol when people
see e10 on those petrol pumps that
suggested up to 10 so the fuel could be
a biofuel coming from those crops if we
could temporarily reduce the amount of
biofuels going into the petrol pumps
that actually does bring back down the
the price of maize in particular quite
significantly washington thinks it's a
terrible idea
well washington and the united states
are heavily invested in uh biofuels and
they see that therefore as part of their
field security but what we'd be talking
about here is a a temporary reduction in
order to stabilize world food prices and
make sure that the poorer countries
around the world can get access to the
food that they need so we think it's the
right thing to do but it is the case of
course the united states is a big player
in biofuel so we're gonna have to work
to try to get them on board well they're
not going to are they in fact they're
trying to block um any change that the
prime minister might come up with at g7
well it doesn't um
we should still argue for the right
thing uh whether or not they they think
they're arguing for the right thing they
well they disagree with it because um
they are thinking as well about their um
their fuel supply and they they see this
is a big part of that and they're
worried about what might happen to fuel
at the fuel plants we think that's uh we
think that's misplaced we think that
actually you could do this temporarily
it would temporarily increase the amount
of wheat and maize on world markets and
would therefore bring food prices down
so we've done the analysis on this we
think it's the right thing to do they've
obviously got a slightly different view
at the moment but that's why you have uh
these international dialogues to to
thrash out these differences and discuss
it yeah but you can't persuade somebody
about your point of view if you don't
actually turn up for meetings that
they're organizing the prime minister
didn't go to a meeting that biden was
hosting
well the prime minister is going to be
at um the the meeting this week there's
a meeting happening at uh bavaria and
then there's a nato meeting uh later in
the week in spain as well um there's
been a lot of international aid
obviously he's coming from the
commonwealth heads of government meeting
and i'm sure if the prime minister
wasn't there there would have been
somebody else attending that meeting in
his place
how are we going to get the grain out of
ukraine
well this is a big challenge there's
there's probably around 25 million tons
of grain possibly more
that is currently stranded in stores
around odessa and to put that into
context at any one time we've got about
250 million tons of wheat in store
around the world
and so although it's a small proportion
of the overall total
in the current context it's quite
significant and unless we can get it out
there won't be uh stores for this year's
harvest to go into so we're looking at
what we can do to help to repair
railways to look at a you know land
bridge so that we can get that wheat out
across a land border it's now very very
perilous to try to
get uh ships uh into the black sea and
so we're ruling out the navy being
involved it's very difficult to do that
because the area is mined and in fact
ukraine themselves
have closed their ports for security
reasons and so there's a whole host of
reasons why it's difficult to get
shipping into the black sea and to take
that wheat out of odessa but we are
looking at what we can do to support
them to make sure they can get it out
and the other you know very sad thing
that we're seeing uh is that russia it
appears are stealing some wheat from
those stores and so what the uk
government is doing is
making available the technology that
we've got to be able to test the
provenance
of wheat we're working with other
countries including australia on this so
that we can ensure that stolen ukrainian
wheat does not find a route to market
okay how do we do that
you can test the dna of the grain and
we've got samples of ukrainian grain we
did a lot of work on this you might
remember the horse meat scandal about a
decade ago the uk is a world leader in
being able to test the provenance that's
the precise precise region in which a
crop was grown
through a testing of dna and that's what
we've made available we're putting
putting on the table one and a half
million pounds to support that work okay
are we inviting president zolensky to
address um parliament
uh i haven't heard that but obviously
he's addressed parliament before so
actually to come along and do that um
well i'm sure that he would he would be
locked too i haven't heard plans for
that obviously that's something that uh
the speaker of the house would would
lead on that uh that type of that's just
the prime minister flying a kite at the
moment then well look he zalenski has
already spoken to um parliament
uh he addressed it uh virtually i'm sure
that president zielinski uh at the
moment has got quite a lot on his plate
uh dealing with the current situation uh
in ukraine but of course i'm sure that
he'd be uh welcome to come and address
our parliament sure that the speaker of
the house would accommodate that if that
were the right thing to do but it's uh
very early to be um to be considering
that at the moment but yeah i'm guessing
you are talking to him about how a land
bridge would work to try and get this
grain out we are working with um yes
ukraine on what it would take to ensure
that they can get some of that wheat out
of odessa and into world markets where
it should be
what do we want turkey to do to try and
help with that
well turkey's obviously got a role to
play it's player in the um you know in
the region and in the in the black sea
uh so uh yes there are discussions there
as well it's it's a difficult situation
because a lot of the rail infrastructure
has been damaged through the war it's
been attacked by the russians and it's
also as i said evidence that the
russians are stealing the wheat and uh
and actually um taking it east and we
just need to to make sure that we can
try to get that rail infrastructure back
so that we can expect but you
acknowledge that it's a matter of life
and death for some countries we were in
somaliland um last week showing that
unless this grain gets there then people
are literally going to starve to death
well a really important thing in a
situation like this is for the rest of
the world to keep their markets open and
that's why
europe the uk and the us are all
absolutely committed to keeping world
markets open because as i said there's
around 250 million tons
of wheat in store around the world and
provided world markets remain open we'll
be able to get
wheat to some of those north african
countries that have been traditionally
quite reliant on ukraine but it's very
important that the world doesn't turn in
on itself and put in place export bans
we need those international grain
markets to function as intended okay
talk to me about the northern ireland
protocol um the first vote on the
protocol from mps later on today i think
we'll get the result this evening
we had the eu ambassador to the uk um on
sophie's program i think yesterday
saying the move is illegal and
unrealistic and talks of a trade war and
retaliation is it really worth it
well the reality is that uh we needed to
do something in this space we've been
talking with the european union now for
some time about making the provisions of
the northern ireland protocol work
effectively um the difficulty we've had
is that the european union have said
we're not allowed to change our mandate
member states have said we're not
allowed to have an opinion on this it's
reserved to the european union and
there's been this circular problem with
the european union just refusing to
revisit their mandate and at some point
therefore you have to
take matters into your own hands and to
clarify in law what the northern ireland
protocol means and that's what we're
doing with this bill and it's important
that we do that because we have some
temporary grace periods in place where
we're not implementing um all of the
full checks uh and not requiring export
health certificates and so on and it's
crucial that those remain because you
know ultimately northern ireland is part
of the uk it's part of our internal
market and you can't have a situation
where
things like the sale of sausages from gb
to northern ireland is outlawed or that
seed potatoes from scotland are not
allowed to be sold in northern ireland
it's a nonsense and so we have to
address it what's changed since we did
the deal you know if we start breaking
deals that we've signed sealed and
delivered then why would other countries
want to do a deal with us
well we're not breaking an agreement
we're bringing clarity to how it should
be interpreted and so the northern
ireland protocol always had provisions
for what they call the specialized
committees uh to iron out points of
detail and to to to work on those
remaining very very technical issues so
whether a seed potato from scotland can
be authorized to be sold
there's established mechanisms for that
but look this is the problem the um the
european union has refused to even
consider that or or refer it to their
technical committee so then clarity
after the deal's already done you can't
do that no you can because uh it was
always involved according to the eu they
say that it's illegal unrealistic and
it's going to be a trade war well that's
not correct uh what's legal is what
parliament deems legal through the
legislation that it passes now obviously
we would still uh rather that the eu did
what they ought to have done many months
ago change their mandate sought out
their position talk to their own member
states about what they should be doing
here and then actually come back to the
table and work out how to make that
northern ireland protocol work but in
the absence of that what we will do and
we can absolutely
you know give them this guarantee we
will protect the interests of the eu
single market in the way we legislate so
we're talking about having red lanes and
green lanes so that goods destined only
for northern ireland won't need checks
but they will stay in northern i think
about goods that are going on to the
single market which still have those
checks so that gives the european union
all of the reassurance that they need
for their own single moment was oven
ready
it was a complete deal but there were
remaining technical details as i said
over often quite uh banal things like
the the technical way that you uh
regulate uh and allow access for things
like seed potatoes and so do you
remember particularly varieties of trees
these are small things that were
there to be resolved after an eu's not
but do you think that the eu would go
into a trade war over banal detail
uh no i don't i think it would be a very
foolish thing for them to do they
obviously think it's more than banal
detail
well i think what they need to to do is
revise their mandates and um re-engage
in discussions from a meaningful basis
having talked to their own member states
that's what we would like them to do in
the absence of that um obviously it
falls to the uk government uh to german
to determine the correct legal
interpretation by changing the law by
changing not changing them by
implementing
an act of parliament that gives us the
ability to derogate from elements of it
where necessary in order to make it work
uh breaking international law is what
the eu say
well we don't accept that because there
are circumstances where you can actually
do this and these are we're talking here
not about uh derogating from the main
principles of the north island protocol
that principle that there should be um
no border on the island of ireland uh
that there should be unfettered trade
between gb
and northern ireland and that remains in
place and we will protect the interests
of the european union's own single
market by having those red lanes and
full checks on those goods so they have
nothing to worry about in that regard uh
we will look after their interest in the
way uh we legislate through the northern
ireland do you think the prime minister
has the full support of his cabinet at
the moment yes
well apart from the one that resigned
last week of course and so oliver darden
has resigned uh and he responded so he
was an outlier and there's no others
well um he resigned and the the way that
collective government works as you know
is that those who are in the cabinet yes
um we we have our full support we work
as a team uh we have the support of the
prime minister the prime minister has
our support we work together and you
know we stick together through difficult
times and so even when yes you have uh
very disappointing election results as
we undoubtedly did last thursday we've
got an important agenda that we're
working on and that's what we're all
focused on okay um how do we feel about
our future kin receiving cash in a
suitcase from a qatari sheikh
look i've seen these uh these reports
you know and i i
i don't have a particular view on it
provided this is all accounted for
properly then obviously that's something
it's something for the royal family to
look at it's going to be reinvesting
it's going to be reinvestigated by the
charity commission yes and obviously
there'll be that investigation and it's
something that for them to look at but
it's not something while an
investigation is going on for me to
comment on well he was previously
chastised by a high court judge um for
calling on the very same shake to
intervene in the development of chelsea
barracks um how wise is it given that
that happened and he was chastised by a
high court judge a decade ago is it to
um accept bags full of cash
look i don't know the details of this
and i'm not i've only seen the news
reporting we don't know uh how true that
news reporting was or whether there were
they've acknowledged that they received
that whether he physically took a bag of
uh money so we don't know any of that
and that's obviously good well there's
obviously an investigation that the
charity commissioner said they're going
to run let's let that run its course
okay just talk to me before i let you go
about um suggestions by nicola sturgeon
friend of your government of course um
suggesting that if margaret thatcher was
still in power there would have been a
second indie referendum by now
well
i don't think um i don't think that's
right and i don't think we should have a
second referendum now we had a
referendum not long ago just in 2014. it
gave a clear result and i think the the
really important thing is there's bigger
issues that we need to work on we've got
all of these global pressures as we're
coming out of the pandemic
that's what we should be focused on and
the it's it's there's too much else
going on in the world at the moment to
be having another referendum okay it's
good to talk to you as always thanks
very much